at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by LegalZoom which has
been a longtime sponsor because I've
seen it help so many different
businesses hundreds and thousands of
businesses of yours as listeners and
even including some guests on this show
such as WordPress lead developer and
automatic founder Matt Mullenweg
LegalZoom is a reliable resource that
more than 1 million people have used to
successfully launch and run businesses
LegalZoom has been helping people take
care of their dreams and legal
responsibilities got to protect those
dreams folks from more than 16 years
they're not a law firm but they have the
resources to keep you on the right path
including advice from their network of
independent attorneys all at your
fingertips whether you want to take your
business to the next level or take
control of your family's future with an
estate plan for instance that's actually
one of the places I started with legal
zooms looking at wills and so on related
to estate planning Legal Zoom has
options so you can take care of the
things that matter most go to
legalzoom.com
and get special savings when you enter
Tim that's capital T IM in the promo box
a check out special savings what does
that mean I'm not sure mystery savings
could be a thousand percent could be one
percent could be ten percent could be
twenty seven and a half percent I don't
know so go to legalzoom.com and get
special savings when you enter Tim in
the pro box a check out that's LegalZoom
calm and use promo code Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites
wordpress.com which i've used for ages
now is the online home for this podcast
Tim dot blog forward slash podcast my
blog and all of my standalone book sites
so whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
creating your website on WordPress com
helps others to find you remember you
and connect with you
WordPress is designed for non-technical
businesses and pluggers that's me I am
NOT getting nitty-gritty in the code you
do not need experience setting up a
website they take care of the technical
side so it's easy to get your site up
and running their customer support team
is available to help 24 hours a day and
not just Monday through Friday but also
weekends and if you look at the bigger
picture 28% of all websites run on
WordPress which is mind-blowing when you
consider it and plans start at just four
dollars per month listeners of this
podcast can receive 15% off any new
planned purchase so go to wordpress.com
forward slash Tim to create your website
and find the plan that's right for you
that's wordpress.com forward slash Tim
for 15% off a brand new web site
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this episode is going
to be a bit of an anomaly an experiment
and instead of my usual long-form
interviews where I deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out
their habits routines favorite books and
so on I will share some details from my
own life and decision making and so on
based on questions that have been
uploaded by subscribers to five bullet
Friday what is fine bullet Friday five
bullet Friday is a free newsletter that
I send out every Friday that includes
the five coolest things I found or
explored that week it can include what
I'm reading books articles gadgets tech
workarounds any type of experiments that
I'm doing favorite purchases etc etc etc
and this newsletter has proven to be
very very popular more than a million
people subscribed has more than a 60
percent open rate for those of you in
the email world you know that is
absolutely astonishing so people do look
forward to this it's free it will always
be phrase if you want to check it out
and there are also exclusive meetups
opportunities to ask me questions and so
on check it out at Tim blog forward
slash Friday
Tim dot blog forward slash Friday and
it's super short five bullet point email
with lots of fun stuff every Friday
something to help you get a little
morsel to chew on for your weekend so
let's just jump right into it
question number one hi Tim what are the
top five health markers to check and
watch regularly this is a very tough
question to answer because so much of it
would be predicated on your personal
situation biochemistry family history
and so on I'm not going to totally dodge
but I will say and I'm paraphrasing here
the words of much wiser doctors that I
work with however above the age of 40 or
so I want to say with a 70% or greater
likelihood you are going to be killed or
you are going to die from one of four
things cancer stroke heart attack or
neurodegenerative disease or
complications thereof looking at family
history you can pretty quickly figure
out which are the primary candidates in
my case it's heart attack and
neurodegenerative disease like
Alzheimer's and so on
therefore many of the things I do both
track and preemptively or preventive ly
treat are going to be related to heart
attack cardiovascular disease or
neurodegenerative disease all right so
that would dictate say the use of
curcumin like I think it's called ethera
cumin something like that for instance
or on the heart attack side looking at
other things but I want to refer
everyone to tim dot blog /a tia ATT IA
this will take you to episodes featuring
dr. peter attea who is one of the best
MDS i know and i know a lot of MDS he
works with many many name-brand folks as
a concierge doctor you would recognize
has very credible background he is
exceptionally evidence-based also former
ultra endurance athlete swimming 25 plus
mile swimming races and things of that
type so he understands and appreciates
the implications and also trade-offs of
say longevity versus performance which
are very often at odds does that mean
you want a hundred percent of one and
none of the other probably not so how do
you navigate that blend in any case
specifically if you go to tuned up blog
/t ax look at episode 65 because he
answers this question in great detail
and i may be getting some of this wrong
but i'm looking at the show notes and
here's what i see listed under medical
terminology apoE genotype
alright this can be indicative of your
predisposition to things like
Alzheimer's LDL particle number alright
particle number is a critical piece of
this LP little a the next we have og TT
that stands for oral glucose-tolerance
test then you have i g f1 insulin-like
growth factor-1 does master all and a
few other things
are listed here and very frequently if
you're talking with say Peter at least
the way that he and I often do things
using either intermittent fasting or
extended periods of fasting say three
contiguous days per month and then
longer periods a few times per year as a
purge fast as discussed in my episode
with dr. Dominic D'Agostino who has
introduced to me by Peter this can be
used as a a plausible preventative
measure to counter cancer which is not
one of my most likely candidates to kill
me personally although it certainly is
for a lot of folks and going between
phases of say hypertrophy meaning muscle
building and performance optimization
alternating that with periods of otology
which you can help trigger this type of
cellular self-cleaning through things
like fasting among others exercise
certainly plays a role all right so long
story short I defer to Peter attea go-to
teamed up log /ta check out episode 65
specifically and this question is
answered as his first question from
y'all alright next I'm going to answer
how do you manage all of your contacts
you know so many people and how they are
all interrelated do you have a specific
system or software to help you and I'm
going to answer this with a non-answer
which is no because I don't want to make
it seem like I have all the answers and
that I'm selectively picking those I
have great answers to which will create
that illusion so no I do not have
software for this I wish I did but
simultaneously I am nervous
I suppose creeped-out would be another
way to put it by the amount of data
Google Facebook and so on have Apple
included and what they're able to
correlate without any input from me for
instance auto correcting names I've been
texting with or that I have off of what
I perceive to be the Apple platform in
my phone or for instance Facebook in
some way
a correlating based on the app use on
the phone people I've just added to
contacts or been texting with or names
I've mentioned with their suggested
people you should know on Facebook all
these things creep me out so I don't
think I put in enough data or detail
into my contacts to make this it's
easily solvable by software because even
if you were to pull by area code say I'm
traveling to Texas so I want to know who
has a 5-1 to area code let's just say so
that I can ask certain people out to
lunch or dinner while people's physical
addresses change more often than their
phone numbers so that is not an accurate
indicator so the short answer is no what
I try to do with my contacts because
rightly I mean you have suppose inferred
by the question that I know thousands
and meet thousands of new people every
single year I try to simply know one or
two people who are very strong in each
given field and through those people I
can get to any one I might need in other
words I'm focusing on just-in-time
introductions and contacts not just in
case contacts and this is a corollary to
something that Kathy Sierra taught me a
long time ago which was to focus on
just-in-time information in other words
knowing how to find the information you
need when you need it as opposed to just
encase information a good example of
that would be reading business books say
on how to sell your company when you're
running a startup in the early stages
because you're going to take notes
promptly forget everything and then have
to reread that book at a later point in
time if you ever pick it up again and
that is a sunk cost
so just-in-time information instead of
just in case information and
just-in-time contacts visa vie one or
two highly competent people in each
field versus collecting hundreds and
thousands of business cards and figuring
out what to do with them which is a more
reactive way to go about it
next question
have you or your guests any strategies
to prevent or minimize binge eating
during periods of stress yes and the
last two weeks have been very stressful
for me I've had many crises pop up at
the same time and it has been very
challenging and I will tell you that the
first rule is to eliminate from the home
anything that you would binge eat and
this really underscores my belief that
your systems Trump willpower you should
rely on proper systems and restrictions
environmentally speaking versus this
thing that we like to think of as
discipline or willpower which is very
fallible and case in point I have come
home from late dinners or say two
glasses of wine during this period of
high stress landed home gone into the
pantry deliberately looking for things
to snack on any bit of chocolate any bag
of potato chips
anything that might remotely qualify as
a cheap food and instead I find mustard
MCT oil athletic greens protein powder
canned beans not interesting whatsoever
as late-night cheap foods and therefore
I don't end up binging when I violate
that for instance about six days ago I
was visiting a consumer packaged goods
company and they gave me three amazing
bags of I'll say potato chips but the
really tortilla chips made from
different types of root vegetables and
so on delicious and came back one night
and what did I do
I had these three bags that are never in
my pantry and I promptly ate all three
bags 2,100 calories of his tortilla
chips and they were delicious did I
regret that yes did I feel guilty yes
did I think less of myself for having
done it yes so keep it out of your house
if you have anything that is achieve
food in your house removed from your
house that is system over well power
number one number two is get your
breakfast right so if you consume
for instance what I would consider
perhaps a ideal breakfast for many
people 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes of waking up which means you
wake up you know breakfast and that
could be say three eggs three whole eggs
what Gretchen Rubin does as well by the
way for those of you who heard her on
the podcast some time ago three eggs
some spinach could be microwaved doesn't
make a difference to me but let's just
say a little bit of spinach so you have
that fiber and then you also have some
type of black beans or lentils or pinto
beans some type of beans and see if
three eggs lentils or beans and then
some spinach the composition of that
meal the macros so to speak the protein
load plus the fiber content will help to
stave off any type of binge inclination
for the rest of the day and there's a
very very good chance if you just fix
that meal if you just dial in that as
your new default breakfast that you will
consume say fifteen to thirty percent
fewer calories for the rest of the day
this is very very common and is also why
if you have a hundred pounds 150 pounds
200 pounds to lose and many people have
done this on the slow carb diet and you
can search how to lose a hundred pounds
slow carb diet for free case studies and
instructions on how to do this with
photographs
I will first ask that they do nothing
other than change their breakfast why it
is a LEED Domino that then has many
downstream effects that you could treat
as independent decisions otherwise but
that would lead to decision fatigue so
why not look at all these decisions and
ask yourself which of these if made or
done correctly would make the others
automatic irrelevant or easier and the
answer is fixing breakfast and there are
other guidelines but really those are
two of the primaries all right next
question
what's next for you now that your book
is launched the book that is referred to
in this question is tribe of mentors
well tribe mentors
yeah thanks to all of you thank you very
very much ended up number one New York
Times number one Wall Street Journal and
it is in orbit so it has reached escape
velocity and it is always my job just to
get the flywheel spinning and if the
book is any good it sticks if not then
it doesn't but this one appears to have
stuck and at this point I view my job as
saying no to a thousand things and
creating space to listen this is along
the lines of what Tim O'Reilly has
shared on this podcast and if you
haven't heard that episode I highly
recommend you check it out if you're
asking yourself Tim who all the more
reason to go check it out but creating
space to listen to really just exist and
develop a higher level of perception so
I am focused on all manner of things to
assist that such as testing a beta
version of the waking up app by my
friend Sam Harris who's also been on
this pod before who manages to somehow
speak in fully formed prose paragraphs
or blocking out time whether that is for
instance this weekend when I will be
going to an air B&B way out in the
country here in Texas with no Wi-Fi no
reception whatsoever or say more
extended trips of two to three weeks
with my family which I do twice a year
after reading the tail-end an essay by
Tim urban on wait but why which put the
remaining number of hours as a
percentage of the total that I was spend
with my family before they died my
parents specifically into perspective or
blocking out an entire month to
hopefully go off the grid without using
any social media or electronics which
I'm in the process of planning now why
would I want to do this I mention this
in brief earlier but developing a higher
sensitivity and ability to perceive this
can be helpful whether you are doing
some explicit type of work such as Cal
Newports deep work say
which requires extended periods of
uninterrupted time blocks of time or if
you are simply trying to be more aware
and develop an awareness of how you feel
how you think how you react in perhaps a
vasana meditation respect so that your
ability to parse life and be less
reactive is developed over time which is
something certainly I'm paying a lot of
attention to right now especially given
the number of crises that have hit in
the last week or two which has proven to
me the value of this type of training
and deliberately creating space to
listen Allah Tim O'Reilly and that is o
apostrophe RR e IL ly for those of you
who wants check it out all right next
question is about EDC everyday carry
what do you keep on your person as part
of your EDC how do you carry it how does
it change during travel or other
activities slash events bonus points if
you do a pocket dump all right short
answer is I have a very unimpressive EDC
when you consider my pant pockets I
don't like keeping things in my pant
pocket so I don't have much I do use a
Patagonia lightweight fleece vest
oftentimes as my walking portable bag
that I wear on myself but the backpack
is is really the standard for man it
travels with me almost everywhere that I
go and I have a number of different pack
packs including one made by dots USADA
da TSU sa RA made out of hemp which was
or is I should say a company created by
a reader after going through the 4-hour
workweek which is fun and in that
backpack there are a number of things
that I travel with at all times
including the rubs ball are ubz ball
looks like a golf ball with little
prongs on it and that was introduced to
me by Amelia Boone four-time world
champion in obstacle course ray
for you say before flights after flights
during any period of travel and it
alleviates tightness and pain not just
in the feet but all the way up through
the legs the posterior chain the hips it
unlocks more than you would expect so
that always travels with me a headlamp I
always have a headlamp in a side pocket
very often Black Diamond sprayable zinc
for bolstering the immune system and
melatonin typically 3 milligram tablets
and everyone from art devaney
to Dominick D'Agostino are fans of
melatonin use of different points buddhu
floss for self-care different types of
joint issues created by Kelly Starrett
you can google that for more a journal
of some type very frequently the 5
minute journal or morning pages but the
morning pages paperback is exceptionally
heavy so I often ditch that earplugs
most frequently max silica and putty
earplugs so you can sleep on say your
side without having fum poke into your
inner ear and then an eye mask of some
type and the sleep master eye mask is
one I use very frequently it also covers
the ears on the outside as opposed to
digging in with an elastic strap the
only caveat is that it can be very warm
so I also collect eye masks from various
flights and so on if you were to look at
what I carried some time ago for
instance when I was writing the 4-hour
chef and got really into prep Orval and
all of that I would have had a
multi-tool in my wallet it would look
like a metal business card with little
nooks and crannies for a Phillips head
screwdriver say saw-edged etc that was
recently confiscated by the TSA surprise
surprise I would also have potentially a
sure-fire
flashlight tactical flashlight in my bag
and then I would have a paracord wrist
band or bracelet of some type if you're
wondering what you could use paracord
for the answer is almost anything
including bow drill which is a bit of an
edge case for all practical purpose
but you can look up bow-drill if you
want to see how to make fire using
something like paracord that is woven
into a bracelet and you could also look
up tim ferriss experiment Las Vegas
escape to see some of the training I did
with OnPoint tactical and Kevin Reeve
where we looked at getting out of zip
ties getting out of handcuffs and all
sorts of other craziness so you can
check that out at your leisure but these
days I don't have a whole hell of a lot
in terms of EDC I suppose now that I
live in Texas I could go get my
concealed carry and that would add a
whole new layer to paranoia danger and
potential offense so there you have it
slash defense all right next up we have
most valuable skills for financial
freedom and being better with money
question mark this is a super dicey
question so I'm going to add a very
important preamble which is I am NOT a
professional investment advisor nor do I
play one on the internet so this is for
informational purposes only a lot of
people take everything I say literally
and that is dangerous so don't do that
use your own brain and much like the
question of what are the five top five
health markers to check and watch
regularly most valuable skills for
financial freedom and being better with
money is highly personalized but what I
would say is that if you are in debt if
you have a substantial amount of debt I
have found for instance or I've
certainly heard from hundreds of
listeners and readers that Dave Ramsey
is very helpful some people are very big
fans of Rich Dad Poor Dad by Kiyosaki
and the quadrant in particular in that
book is something that many have found
useful
ramit sethi good friend of mine
our ami TSE thi is very adept and I
think very smart in this particular
arena and if you want to look up
automated Finance
system Ram eat RA MIT and then Tim
Farriss he has a guest blog post on my
blog that is very very popular has been
very popular over the years and is worth
taking a look at so I do think that if
you are in debt those three places are
good places to start beyond that I can
really only speak from personal
experience but financial freedom can
entail a lot and can mean many things to
different people
that could mean lack of debt it could
mean being able to do whatever you want
in which case the the sky is the limit
perhaps you need tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of dollars if you
want to buy that jet it could mean
financial freedom that you are free from
financial worry
it no longer occupies 20% of your RAM at
all times and being better with money
alright I would divide being better with
money into two different categories and
keeping in mind that for me a good
investment is one that increases your
quality of life why otherwise would you
invest so if you say are invested in
crypto and the percentage gains are very
attractive but you're a complete
crackhead compulsively checking the
charts every 15 minutes is that a good
investment well that's a question for
you to sit with but if it progressively
worsens your quality of life or
consistently creates more anxiety than
you had beforehand
is the marginal utility of the dollars
you are gaining as reflected in that
percentage enough to offset that with
some type of lump sum payment of
happiness or improved quality of life at
the end maybe not but this is something
worth considering coming back to what I
was saying though I tend to think of
money as getting rich staying rich so
there are different tools in the toolkit
for getting rich different tools then in
the staying rich category
and I would say if you're looking at
beating the market so alpha I don't do
that
in the hands-off styles of investing I I
have that very much on one side of my
barbell so I personally partially by
choice and partially by fate have ended
up with a very barbell looking asset
distribution and if you were to look at
what I have you're gonna have highly
volatile what most people will consider
highly risky class of investments namely
startups and cryptocurrency that's going
to be more than 50 percent of my total
assets and then you have real estate and
cash or cash like equivalents and that's
pretty much it so on opposite ends of
the spectrum and we could debate whether
or not real estate is risky we could
debate the benefits of cash if you also
have to contend with inflation but let's
just keep its simple for the sake of
this discussion and say that you have
highly volatile what most people would
consider high-risk high-reward
categories like privately held startups
and cryptocurrency on one end of the
barbell which is where I create my alpha
and then you have real estate cash cash
like equivalents and things like for
instance muni bonds and so on where you
would then preserve that alpha okay so
you create alpha take it off the table
and then preserve alpha now forget about
the question of converting crypto into
fiat or keeping it and crypto let's just
keep it simple so that is currently what
my say asset allocation would look like
that is very very likely to change over
time and I should address a couple of
questions that likely come to mind one
would be why on earth do you have more
than 50% of your net worth in startups
in crypto and it is not because I had a
hundred units of assets and decided to
put 50 plus percent
those units into crypto and startups
that would be complete insanity I think
for almost anyone it's because I started
off with a very reasonable allocation
some of you might remember that many
years ago 2008 or so I created for
myself a real world MBA rather than
going to a Stanford GSB or one of these
graduate school programs of business I
decided to take the same amount of money
over two years at that point of $60,000
a year for two years and invest that
into the Tim Ferriss fund in quotation
marks to try my hand at startup
investing in the very beginning
piggybacking and Co investing with
people who knew what they were doing and
I assumed the network built the skills
developed the knowledge acquired over
that two-year period of time would
benefit me more than the $120,000 which
I assumed I would lose the assumption
was much like tuition that would be a
sunk cost and that then set me on this
accidental career of being an
early-stage tech angel investor and
advisor and that tiny sliver of my total
pie chart at that time due to lucky
slash good investments and company
selection has swollen to a gigantic
percentage of the total pie chart with
companies like uber Facebook Twitter
Alibaba and so on crypto very similarly
has not necessarily risen as it would
have had I gone in early with something
like aetherium but has nonetheless
doubled and so on over time more than
doubled so if you look at my cost basis
it was a very rational well semi
rational decision at the time to
allocate what I allocated but due to
growth they now represent a very very
large percentage of my total holdings
and the crypto can be freely traded the
startups are locked up alright so I am
unable to decrease my positions and
balance those for the most part and that
is why my
for though it looks the way it does I
would not recommend my asset allocation
to really anyone now this comes back to
the question of financial freedom
getting better with money if we're
looking at the the getting rich part the
building wealth for a less crass way to
put it building wealth preserving wealth
sounds a lot fancier much more
Rockefeller than nouveau riche so let's
stick with that right building wealth
preserving wealth the way that I have if
we're assuming there's some aspect of
skill involved and that I'm not just
lucky lucky lucky lucky which could be
the case right if you have a thousand
orangutangs flip coins long enough as
Warren Buffett would say well actually
Warren Buffett wouldn't say this the
efficient Markey market theorist
folks would say this you know a thousand
monkeys flipping coins eventually you're
gonna find one or two monkeys who flip
you know 50 heads in a row and then end
up writing books about how to flip coins
and so on so maybe I'm that monkey but
if we assume there's some element a
skull the way that I've thought about it
is number one capping downside first
versus evaluating upside and looking at
the minimal downside and this is
borrowed from a lot of folks including
some famous names you might recognize
Warren Buffett for instance who's a
would be considered I think by most a
value investor oh the Charlie Munger has
certainly informed their there later
investment styles Paul Tudor Jones yeah
of hedge fund Fame and this is actually
a quote that I took from Tony Robbins
book unshakable which is which is very
good or money master the game also very
very good is this truly the hard trade
this is from Paul Tudor Jones
paraphrasing is this truly the heart
rate question mark meaning something
others can't easily replicate does this
really have a symmetric risk reward is
it a five to one or a three to one that
means for every dollar he is risking is
there the potential or expectation of a
three or five dollar ROI what's the
entry point
your stops these are all really really
good questions and the downside risk
happening the downside risk is also
something that for instance Richard
Branson does and when he started Virgin
Atlantic negotiating a lease with Boeing
so that he could return the plane or
planes if it didn't work out so even
these people who are viewed as
inveterate risk takers people who throw
caution to the wind are in fact
determining how to limit their downside
right up front and looking for
asymmetric wrists so in the startup
world that checked the box you can put
in 25k max you know your maximum that
you can lose because you're not using
leverage or anything else 25k is the
maximum you can lose and yet there is
the potential if you focus on an unfair
advantage and we'll come back to that
that you could have a hundred two
thousand x return and the startup world
much like publishing book publishing
music these are hits driven businesses
and you are betting on companies or
books or musicians or albums that you
hope will return the fund they will
return all of the other losses that you
will incur with your other bets and I do
very well with those types of decisions
they are binary they are not day trading
they're certainly not considering buying
or selling on a regular basis at which
point you become very susceptible to mr.
market if you want to look up warren
buffett mr. market that is who i am in
public markets so I do not play much
with public li traded equities for
instance even though that might be part
of my portfolio later instead I like to
do a ton of research upfront make a
binary decision am I in am I out and
then I'm stuck and that being stuck is
actually a benefit it is a constraint
that works for me in this case because I
can't make sell decisions at the wrong
time it is out of my hands that does not
suit everyone's intestinal fortitude it
just happens to suit my weird psychology
the unfair advantage I mentioned I would
come back to
is really only playing with a stacked
deck so I do not make investments in
startups where I cannot materially
impact directly the value of that
company or from the selection standpoint
when I have unless I have a significant
informational advantage and when I lived
in Silicon Valley I was there for 17
years I lived in the middle of the
switch box and I made every effort to
ensure that I was in the hub of
information flow so I knew about things
weeks months in some cases years in
advance and that enabled me to make
better decisions as to where I should
allocate the tim ferriss fund in their
first two years certainly which worked
out very very well and had some great
teachers who have all talked about their
approaches for investing on this podcast
navall ravikant incredible you can go to
tim dot blog /in Deval you can go to tim
vlog forward slash let's see actually
might not be a forward slash but if you
look up Mike maples ma ple s he's
another one who's been very very
consistently good and so on and so forth
all right so this is a long answer but
for financial freedom first
understanding how to get out of debt or
how to manage debt I use very very
little debt in my life some people are
very comfortable with that I am NOT and
being better with money is in part not
being afraid of money and also learning
how to take small steps and moderate
actions with limited downside rather
than being paralyzed by any insecurities
or fears you might have about money
that's a book that I think holistically
can help with that is how to stop
worrying and start living by Dale
Carnegie has nothing directly to do with
money but it does have everything to do
with how you might interact with money
the last thing I would say is coming
back again to financial freedom is to
correct a misconception about
the spectrum between full-time employed
and entrepreneur there is the erroneous
belief the false dichotomy that these
things exist completely separately in
other words that you you're either a
nine to fiver or work for someone else
or you quit that job and chase your
dreams in your full-time entrepreneur I
don't recommend in most cases that you
make that black-and-white leap in fact
it makes much more sense to moonlight
two side gig on say the weekends or
Saturdays for a period of time so that
you can both assess and evaluate your
ideas for a company but also assess and
evaluate your own abilities as an
entrepreneur to for instance structure
time that is otherwise unstructured to
set your own rules and policies instead
of having them set by someone else or
some type of company environment and not
everyone is suited to the uncertainty
that you face as an entrepreneur on an
ongoing basis and there's nothing wrong
with that
it's it comes down to accurately
assessing your strengths and weaknesses
which certainly applies to investment
and guess what it's all investment
investment of money time energy
attention these are all investment
decisions all right I covered the asset
allocation and why you should never copy
me and let's go to the next all right hi
Tim I know this is a bit out of your
normal focus but I'm curious do you have
philosophy about having or not having
children this is one of the undecided
categories so hopefully my my somewhat
non answer will be reassuring to people
who are in a similar place but I'm
conflicted about this because on on one
hand if we're talking about investing
and betting let's just say if I look at
the divorce rates in the United States
and the damage that can be done
certainly based on talking to my friends
who are the the children of divorce
parents by divorce I wouldn't bet on
marriage the instant
tution to supports or rather to have a
fantastic outcome if i were betting on
on partnerships the way that i would bet
on startups i wouldn't bet on
partnerships period long term whether
they're within the confines of marriage
or have some other arrangement so so
there's a lot of hesitancy on my part
for all those reasons the there are
other ways to look at this of course
there there are friends of mine who are
either divorced or are probably headed
towards divorce and i would ask them if
the only way they could have their kids
was to get married knowing they would
absolutely get a divorce but they still
have their kids and the answer is
invariably yes now is this confirmation
bias at this point probably it would be
very hard for any parent with a heart to
say absolutely not I would unwind the
clock and not have my kids I've yet to
meet anyone who has said that and then
there are folks for instance Jersey Greg
wreck the olympic weightlifting champion
who is 63 right now I believe and I
would consider one of my mentors he's in
my TED talk if you're interested to
learn more about him Tim not block
forward slash Ted but he has said to me
privately I don't think you'd mind me
sharing this but he's like yeah so I
asked him how I should think about kids
they said well you know if you're a guy
you get past the age of X I think you're
saying like 4550 and you don't have kids
he's like that's just weird
he's a very direct he's like you just go
crazy inside your own head if you don't
have kids by that point and I I think
the simplicity that is actually really
profound and that the fact of the matter
is I may get to a point where my
biological imperative the Darwinian
evolution that has led me to this point
being alive on this planet in this
particular period in time to want to
have kids or and feel the need to have
kids despite any arguments to the
contrary and
at that point I might say [ __ ] it and
pull the trigger and have kids although
I recognize that it's not always that
simple and a lot of men assume that the
fertility piece of the equation is
problematic if the woman has problems
but I will tell you right now given the
trending that I have seen in morphology
motility in sperm among men and
decreases in testosterone and everything
else due to factors we can cover another
time
that it's never quite or very often not
as simple as people would like to think
and that the fertility problems
experienced by couples are very much are
very often attributable to the men and
not necessarily the women all right next
you often ask your interviewees for
their advice for a younger person or a
younger version of themselves what
advice have you distilled from your
guests or your own experience that would
be appropriate for those over 40 and
I'll keep this super short this answer
or I say this question and the assorted
answers from guests are most represented
in my last two books tools of Titan's
and especially tribal mentors where you
see many many many many different
options and with rare exception the
advice that would apply to those over 40
is exactly the same advice that that
these various guests would give to
younger people with the exception of
perhaps risking it all in some capacity
because you you don't have mortgages you
don't have kids right so apart from the
hey kid you should try the crazy stuff
because you have no mortgage no kids no
real responsibilities aside from that
advice which is really a small subset
maybe 10 to 15% of the answers all of
the rest of the advice applies the
reason I asked what would you what
advice would you give your younger self
or what advice would you give a high
school senior or a college senior is
that the people I'm interviewing feel
qualified to give that advice whereas if
I said what advice would you give
to every 40 year old and their 35 or
their 45 or maybe even 60 they will be
more reserved in in the prescription of
advice for those older groups than they
then they will be with the younger
groups and so it's it's really a
tactical decision on my part also just
to get a more relaxed less edited answer
from these people all right next
question do you think people who are
introverted should practice develop
learn to be more extroverted or just
embrace being introvert eating to both I
would consider myself an introvert at
least as defined by someone who is
recharged by being alone or with very
very few people and I've never taken the
myers-briggs test but I'm constantly
told I'm an INTJ second most frequent I
suppose
well the precise turn diagnosis would be
int P but certainly I would consider
myself an introvert who has trained
himself to for short periods of time be
an extrovert and get up on stage and
give speeches and so on but I avoid
large groups nearly all of the time and
even if I go to a large dinner party I
will frequently take five-minute breaks
every half-hour so just to recharge and
gather my bearings so they take a lot of
bathroom breaks when I go to group
events or conferences or anything like
that so you don't need to be more
extroverted at all it depends a lot on
your goals but they're certainly very
introverted high performers with
exceptional careers both inside of
companies as employees or intrapreneurs
and then outside of companies or in
their own companies as entrepreneurs and
even CEOs you do not need to be a
flamboyant PT Barnum Steve Jobs type to
be an effective executive at all so it's
it's really dependent on your objectives
I will say that I agree with Warren
Buffett that public speaking is one of
the best investments you can make some
type of training
course believed that he was part of
Toastmasters or may have just been a
course he took in public speaking but
when you take the ability to communicate
messages effectively to groups of people
and layer it on top of almost anything
else you automatically put yourself into
rarefied company so public speaking I do
think is a useful skill and in fact even
a necessary skill depending on where
your decision tree takes you in life so
that would be one addition even if you
are introverted I would suggest getting
better at some type and practicing
public speaking all right next question
how do you arrange the interior of your
home example given layout items
displayed restored furnishings etc to
optimize your mental state and
effectiveness is this a consideration
yes this is a major consideration for me
and I'm not perfect by any stretch of
the imagination but I do spend a lot of
time at home and I would say just a few
things are particularly important to me
I dislike clutter in any of my living
spaces like a living room for instance
I'm in my living room right now I have
artwork up that elicits very positive
emotions for me and I have books up that
elicit positive enabling emotions or
memories for me so for instance I have
up on the wall I photograph that Matt
Mullenweg my buddy CEO of automatic and
one of the lead developers of WordPress
took when we were traveling in Vietnam
and that is up on a shelf to remind me
of that particular trip where I was able
to say no and take time off the grid
without any side effects or negative
consequences that I can recall and then
I have a book from Chaco willing that is
the discipline equals freedom field
manual because I'm a fan of Jocko and
whenever I'm being complete wimp
with any decisions I need to make
ownership I need to take or discomfort I
need to face then Jacko's on the shelf
yelling at me there I have the ketogenic
Bible a book called less is more jazz an
anthology of writing on minimalism
I have the essential Rumi poetry a book
called braiding sweetgrass the novel
Musashi two books on Musashi actually
Miyamoto Musashi who is thought to be
one of the greatest if not the greatest
swordsman in Japanese history a book
called the book of laughter and
forgetting by Milan Kundera which I have
a lot of positive association with Ray
Dalio principles and then go boards and
other things woodblock prints and I'm
listing off a few things here just so
you have an idea a photograph of an
Olympic weightlifter in a training hall
doing clean-and-jerk with several
hundred pounds the nameplate in effect
it's a piece of fabric that was stitched
into the back of my judo uniform when I
competed in judo as an exchange student
in Japan at age 15 so I unstitched that
from my judogi when I was 15 and I've
carried it with me ever since with my
name and my school name underneath that
and so on and so forth a lot of wildlife
a lot of scenery so I have panoramic
shots of waterfalls and ponds in the
Pacific Northwest like Oregon I have
photograph of a gigantic grizzly bear
coming out of the water
I think it's called majesty rising which
is a photograph by Paul Nicklin a
National Geographic photographer he was
just incredible and one of the few
people I follow one of the few
photographers I follow on Instagram
Christina mitr Meyer as well would be
would be high up but yes I think a lot
about what is placed around my home and
what type of emotional states they
prompt so that is short answer to that
all right next question
productivity for non type-a people much
of your advice and that of your guests
seems to be aimed at people who thrive
with setting and maintaining routines do
you have advice for those of us who are
ambitious but see routines is an
undesirable daily grind yes I do have
advice and it is not avoid routines it
is to reframe routines
as something enabling it is a positive
constraint that allows you to avoid
decision fatigue and allocate your
brainpower and the creative competitive
advantages to the things that actually
matter which is not choosing what to
have for breakfast in the morning or
deciding which coffee shop to go to etc
routines and I think this is WH out and
I'm getting the name correct should be
seen as a in the intelligent man be seen
that's of course people in general seen
in the intelligent man as a sign of
ambition so instead of seeing routines
as an undesirable daily grind to reframe
routines rituals if you prefer that word
as scaffolding around which you can
craft your best life without that every
day is a free-for-all and it's it's
effectively an unwritten script that you
have to write every single day before
you can even think about how to perform
the script best you have to write it and
that draws upon your very limited
resources in an incredible draining way
in my experience so my answer is not to
get rid of routines not to avoid
routines but to reframe them as the
scaffolding the reliable scaffolding
around which you can then build your
best life every day and utilize your
unique strengths in the least wasteful
way possible all right next question and
I only have four or five left here all
right so the next question is how is
life in Austin have you designed or
chosen a new house according to any
changes you've wanted to make in your
lifestyle as I'll answer the first piece
austin is great i've living in Austin
has made me fall more in love with the
city than simply visiting and that was a
concern I wasn't sure what it would be
like living here as an austenite but
it's absolutely spectacular and I'm
exceptionally exceptionally bullish on
Austin so I've doubled and tripled and
quadrupled down on this town a very very
very big fan I'll keep it short but if
you haven't visited at the very least
live music capital of the u.s. fantastic
barbecue friendly people
it's it's a great town so I encourage
everybody to check it out next questions
what questions should a person ask
themselves to determine their ware of
happiness I've talked about where of
happiness and how I ended up at Austin
for myself the easiest way to determine
and just as context people think about
the what what should I do
the who should I spend time with the why
etc of determining their optimal
happiness what job should I do and what
type of people should I spend time
around and the wear is very important
the geography the city or state place in
which you put yourself that determines a
lot of these other things my
recommendation is to do an 80/20
analysis of your last calendar year so
I'm recording this in late February but
it doesn't really matter go back and
look at your calendar for the last year
this should only take an afternoon
really you can do it on a Saturday for
instance or Sunday and go through and
you you will fill in two columns the
first column is the 20% of people or
activities that produced peak positive
emotional states most of the time right
peak positive emotional states the the
20% of say people and activities that
produced 80% of the joy so to speak on
the other side you're gonna have the 20%
of people or activities that produced
80% of the negative emotional states the
irritation the frustration the annoyance
the anger etc and you're gonna make a
list in that column that's gonna be your
not to-do list all right then you're
gonna look at the positive and you're
gonna look for different locations that
have a high density slash ease of
encountering those things so for
instance I noticed in my own calculus
that AcroYoga correlated to a high
degree of happiness for me if I practice
AcroYoga a few times a week you want to
see what the hell that is
just look up acro yoga like acrobatic
yoga acro yoga Tim Ferriss on the
youtubes
you can also go to youtube.com forward
slash Tim Ferriss and you'll see some
video of this including me putting Jimmy
Fallon up on my feet and I then looked
on Facebook at different cities and the
AcroYoga community in Austin Texas is
gigantic it's larger at least based on
Facebook then the acro yoga community in
the Bay Area where it was created which
blew my mind so that was then one of the
positive check boxes when I was looking
for density / ease of things based on
the calendar audit that have created a
reliable degree of happiness and
improved quality of life through doing
that exercise so that's what I would do
next up if for some reason or another
you could record only one more podcast
who do you interview and why they can be
dead or alive I would interview my
parents because I would want to have
that record really just for myself of
having a long-form conversation with
them and capturing their story and their
wisdom I don't think I would share that
for public consumption but just for me
which is actually a recommendation then
I received from a name that I mentioned
earlier in this podcast Matt Mullenweg
one of the sweetest smartest guys I know
who's also been on this podcast talking
about building companies automatic his
company's worth more than a billion
dollars at this point I believe and has
a distributed architecture for 500
employees it's really fascinating in any
case he made that recommendation to me
and this is a good reminder to get on it
so thanks for that Matt and thanks for
this question to remind me next question
what are the pros cons of a silent
retreat the pros would be similar to
some psychedelic experiences not that I
would recommend those in any illegal
context or in unsupervised fashion
whatsoever but when you do a 10-day
silent retreat which I made
significantly harder for myself by
fasting during so I fasted for about
seven days - prior to ensure that I was
key to adapted five during for the first
half of my 10-day silent retreat it that
type of experience shows you the breadth
and depth of experience possible through
meditation so you will see the best you
will see the worst you will be listless
then you will be you will be not
fatigued you will be restless you don't
want you'll be bouncing off the walls
with no real clear explanation you will
have profound moments of peace and and
thoughtlessness where your ego seems to
dissolve and then you will have times
when like me right before I broke my
fast the only two thoughts in my head
were fried chicken calamari and fried
chicken calamari fried chicken calamari
for like three hours and then the next
day it was like a sporran a sporran just
thinking about porn basically for three
hours which this might sound reasonably
good it was awful particularly when
you're trying to focus on your breathing
or do something else other than think
about such things so it will show you
the breadth and depth of the experience
possible through meditation and that can
then inform your later practice so when
you have these perhaps rare or at least
intermittent experiences of profound
peace and the feeling at ease with
yourself and everything in the world and
perhaps even the dissolution of the self
in the sense that you feel connected to
all people all things that can be a very
tantalizing epiphany beautiful
experience that then motivates you to
meditate later similar to the effect
that psychedelics had on Sam Harris PhD
who I mentioned earlier who then has has
passed on psychedelics no longer uses
psychedelics but used that experience
that promise so to speak the light at
the end of the tunnel having the
firsthand opportunity to do that through
psychedelics to then drive his
meditation practice which is now very
very well developed and a lifeline for
him that is available at any given
moment right so those are few of the
pros of the silent retreat cons all
right and not unlike a powerful
psychedelic experience
I would say out of a hundred people ten
to 15% are going to have a as close to a
psychotic break as one can imagine or an
actual psychotic break and that is
terrifying
and I was in that ten to 15% in the
silent retreat and I think I had a
longer conversation about this with Dan
Harris on his podcast 10% happier and
also on a an episode of this podcast
which should be out by the time you hear
this or it's coming up very very shortly
after this episode with jack Kornfield
and who was in fact the person who saved
me and allowed me to return to have him
my feet on the ground well enough to
leave the silent retreat after that
10-day silent retreat at spirit rock in
Whittier California so I would encourage
you if you want more details on that oh
you didn't expect to be in that ten to
15% which you weren't even told in
advance but congratulations / oh you are
in that 10 to 15% and you can really be
destabilized in a very serious way by
such an experience so I encourage you to
check out Dan Harris podcast with me for
more on that
or even better perhaps is to listen to
my very in-depth conversation with jack
Kornfield
about exactly this all right two more
questions why have you not Illustrated
or sketched in your books you've
mentioned a few times that you dreamed
of being becoming a sketch artist why
not experiment in your books and this is
true I was actually an illustrator
through much of high school and part of
college for paying my expenses and then
I just stopped there's also the graphics
editor of the Princeton tiger magazine
at Princeton when I was there and have
designed all of the covers of my books
with the exception of tools of titans
then have had professional illustrators
designers come in to do the production
versions but I have drawn out all the
covers of my books starting with 4-hour
workweek the so there's no reason I
couldn't do a 60-second sketch each day
for say Instagram but the books of the
after the Polish I don't want to serve
up my trial runs in a book but many of
the illustrations that you see and say
for our chef were in fact originally
sketched out by me and then the Polish
was thrown on for the production by
someone who actually does that as a
full-time job but if you guys would like
to see me do a say a 60 second sketch
each day or I don't know 60 second
Sunday or something like that where I
throw up one drawing a week that would
be a good way for me to get back into it
so maybe I'll do that let me know what
you guys think okay and the last
question Tim I'm a huge fan of how you
constantly experiment and challenge
yourself so I'm asking you to push me
and your other listeners to do a 30-day
challenge I am happy to do that and in
fact it's the same challenge that I am
assigning myself and it's one that I've
done before this is not a thirty day and
make it easier the 21 day no complaint
experiment and you can put this in your
calendar certainly there is an
overabundance of negativity complaining
and criticism on the Internet and we
lose fact 'iv we lose sight of the fact
that it is really positive reinforcement
and applauding what you want and not
exclusively punishing or criticizing
what you do not like or want that
elicits change you do need certainly at
least both and positive reinforcement
and that goes for yourself and your
inner monologue your inner voice as well
so you want to improve your life and
this has already been tested by tens of
thousands of folks via the blog if you
want to tip the Domino like we discussed
earlier that affects many many other
Domino's it increases your quality of
life doing a 21-day no complaint
experiment is a really really effective
way to go about that and it also very
quickly eliminates just how often most
of us complain without any type of
outcome or action coming out of it so
check it out if you go to Tim blog
forward slash complaint I created
redirect so Tim dot blog forward
complaint that will take you to a blog
post which you will see as little dated
- don't mind the discussion of switching
to the Mac that was some time ago but
the headline is real mind control and
then subtitle the 21-day no complaint
experiment and it takes you right
through exactly how to do it and exactly
how I'm going to be doing it starting
all right yeah so check it out Tim vlog
forward slash complaint that is the
21-day challenge that I would recommend
to everyone and that is it that is the
last question so with out dragging this
out too long I would say if you'd like
to ask me questions directly if you
would like to see what I am finding most
interesting in any given week whether
that's articles gadgets new apps elegant
tech fixes and workarounds that a lot of
my friends share with me new investments
you name it
really anything cool that I am
experimenting with that I found that I'm
pondering
I sent out five short bullets every
Friday in five bullet Friday and you can
sign up for free it's always free and
it's fun people love it more than a
million subscribers 60-plus percent open
rate on average it's a lot of fun for me
to put together and people seem to be
enjoying it's check it out you can sign
up at Tim dot blog forward slash Friday
that's Tim dot blog forward slash Friday
and as always until next time thank you
so so much for listening hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all a
spell out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which has been a longtime
sponsor because I've seen it help so
many different businesses hundreds and
thousands of businesses of yours as
listeners and even including some guests
on this show such as WordPress lead
developer and automatic founder Matt
Mullenweg LegalZoom is a reliable
resource that more than 1 million people
have used to successfully launch and run
businesses LegalZoom has been helping
people take care of their dreams and
legal responsibilities got to protect
those dreams folks from more than 16
years do not a law firm but they have
the resources to keep you on the right
path including advice from their network
of independent attorneys all at your
fingertips whether you want to take your
business to the next level or take
control of your family's future with an
estate plan for instance that's actually
one of the places I started with legal
zooms looking at wills and so on relate
to estate planning Legal Zoom has
options so you can take care of the
things that matter most go to
legalzoom.com
and get special savings when you enter
Tim that's capital T IM in the promo box
a check out special savings what does
that mean I'm not sure mystery savings
could be a thousand percent could be one
percent could be ten percent could be
twenty seven and a half percent I don't
know so go to legalzoom.com and get
special savings when you enter Tim in
the pro box and check out that's
legalzoom.com
and use promo code Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites wordpress
comm which i've used for ages now is the
online home for this podcast Tim Doug
forward slash podcast my blog and all of
my standalone book sites so whether
you're looking to create a personal blog
a business site or both creating your
website on wordpress.com helps others to
find you remember you and connect with
you WordPress is designed for
non-technical businesses and cloggers
that's me
I am NOT getting nitty-gritty in the
code you do not need experience setting
up a website they take care of the
technical side so it's easy to get your
site up and running their customer
support team is available to help 24
hours a day and not just Monday through
Friday but also weekends and if you look
at the bigger picture 28% of all web
sites run on WordPress which is
mind-blowing when you consider it in
plans start at just four dollars per
month listeners of this podcast can
receive 15% off any new planned purchase
so go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim
create your website and find a plan
that's right for you that's
wordpress.com or slash tim for 15% off a
brand new web site
you
you